Narrator: Tonight,
Silicon Valley billionaire
Chris Sacca returns to the Tank,
where entrepreneurs seek
an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
A lot of people just gravitate
towards this idea.
We are completely
revolutionizing early education.
Let me show you how it works.
Narrator: If the Sharks hear
a great idea...
Hmm.
Narrator: ...they'll invest
their own money...
You have a lot of passion
about what you're doing.
Narrator: ...and fight
each other for a deal.
-Are you really that clueless?
-No, I'm just -- I'm --
It's a crappy idea.
Why are you yelling at me?
It's not my company.
Narrator:
But the entrepreneurs must get
the full amount
they're asking for...
Have you invested
any money in this?
Yes.
Can we have a moment of silence
for that dead money?
Narrator: ...or they'll
walk away with nothing.
I see all the challenges,
and that's why we're here.
I haven't heard
you speak up, Mark.
I'm listening, right?
Mind your own business,
if you don't mind, "Mr. Baldy."
It's evil!
This is the worst idea
I've ever heard on "Shark Tank."
[ Laughs nervously ]
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Daymond John dominated
the fashion world with Fubu.
Now he's the branding expert
behind multiple global brands
generating billions in sales.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's premier
$2 billion real-estate empire.
And Mark Cuban, esteemed
billionaire, tech mogul,
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
And billionaire investor
Chris Sacca left
his high-profile position
at Google
at the height of his career
to start
his own venture-capital fund,
which is now
one of the highest-performing
investment funds in history,
with early investments
in Twitter, Instagram, and Uber.
First into the Tank is
a modern way to find
and buy the latest styles.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Amy Roiland,
and I live
in Los Angeles, California.
I'm the C.E.O. and founder
of FashionTap.
I'm currently seeking $100,000
for 10% of my company.
FashionTap is
a fashion, social-networking app
that puts bloggers, brands,
and other influencers
at your fingertips.
FashionTap allows
anyone to make money
off the clothing
that they're already wearing.
Let me show you how it works.
FashionTap users create content
on the app, tag it,
and then share it
with their followers.
You can tag anything from
your eye shadow to your shoes.
This is Erica.
Erica's a fashion blogger.
Erica's followers
already look to her
for fashion inspiration and how
to style the latest trends.
With FashionTap,
if her followers are drawn
to a tagged item, like this
gorgeous statement necklace,
they can just tap that tag,
and that tag will take them
directly to the online store
where that item is available
for purchase.
Now, Erica makes
a commission on each sale,
so she's incentivized
to tag what she's wearing.
And on FashionTap,
her followers never have to ask,
"Where did you get that," again.
Brands and retailers love us
because bloggers
and online influencers are
the newest
and best way
to market your brands.
FashionTap was born
out of my love of fashion
and my dream of connecting
the whole fashion world.
Let's make it happen.
Okay, so,
this is already happening
on multiple platforms --
Instagram, Facebook.
Why you?
What do we need you for?
Right.
So, I'm a fashion blogger.
There's a huge void
in fashion networking.
Instagram is not comparable,
really, to what I've created.
You can't directly
tag products on there.
If someone posts sunglasses,
they can tag the brand name,
but they can't tag
that exact thing
that you can buy.
And they're not incentivized,
and they don't get money.
Aren't you concerned
that Instagram could
just add links
to their tags?
Not really because Instagram is
an everybody network.
It's not a fashion network.
And when you hashtag "fashion,"
you see dogs, food.
It's getting more and
more cluttered in that sense.
No question.
You can also post
your Instagram photos
onto the app, and everything's
written there for you.
Just tag it.
How do you make money
doing this?
Okay, so, we have
three revenue streams.
The first one is e-commerce
that I'm currently building
into the app right now.
And so,
off the big-box retailers,
we take 10% of every sale.
But then, those retailers have
to put all that stuff
in your inventory
and make it tagable, right,
in order for them
to agree to your deal.
Right, so,
when we're building that out,
we would negotiate with them
and do direct.
What are the bloggers doing?
Well, those are hard deals
to do, right?
Corcoran: Have you tried to do
any of those deals
with a big-box store?
As a blogger,
I work with Free People,
Jeffrey Campbell --
like, pretty big brands.
I have a lot of followers,
so I do have
those direct connections.
So, once I build this database,
or the user base, up,
I think that it won't be
too hard.
You've got to have enough people
for them to be interested.
Exactly, so --
How many downloads
have you had?
What's your
monthly active users?
So, we have
6,000 downloads to date.
We just launched --
-Over what period of time?
-Six months.
-Six months, okay.
So we just launched
the soft launch six months ago.
And our monthly
active users is 1,500.
And it's been
really organic marketing
through just my channels
and me being a blogger.
So, I haven't done any
paid advertising or anything.
The second revenue stream
would be sponsorships.
So, we would
facilitate sponsorships
with big brands, right?
So, they would send me
the denim jackets plus money,
and then I would pay out
the top users, bloggers,
and models or influencers
on the app to wear those jackets
in several different ways
and style them.
And then, we'd put them
on the "popular" page
so you could see
all these girls --
you know, different sizes
of girls wearing these outfits
in different ways.
How much money would that
girl get who's modeling that
for you, for example?
-Okay, so that would be
the third one, which is
affiliate links built in.
So, if somebody clicks
and buys any of this stuff
that these girls are tagging,
they're gonna get anywhere
between 3% and 35% of that sale,
dependent on what the retailer
has done with the affiliate.
What's your revenue
with that model now?
Okay, so, since the six months,
we have $60,000.
Your first six months
in business,
and you have $60,000
in sales.
How much have you netted
from that?
And that means $6,000
would be?
So what we would get would be
the 1% to 15% of that $60,000.
-But what have you gotten?
-$6,000.
We haven't taken anything
because I'm giving it
all back to the users,
the bloggers, so they --
So you're giving them the
full affiliate fee right now.
-Yes.
-Amy, how are you eating?
Why aren't you starved
to death now?
I'm really excited about this.
I think this is --
I know,
but you can't eat excitement.
How are you living?
I'm living off my savings,
and I have a chairman.
He's fronted $90,000
to create the app.
How much of the company
does he own?
38%.
And I have 33%.
I'd say $90,000 to get this far
is actually really good.
Who owns the rest
of the company?
Yes, so, my C.O.O. has 5%,
and my C.T.O. has 23%.
And then 1%
to the developer.
Well, what do you need
the money for?
I want to use the $100,000
for strictly marketing.
-Yeah.
-That's it.
I won't be paying myself.
I just want
to use it for marketing
to really get
my user base higher.
What are you gonna do
if it doesn't work?
Because getting --
going from six months in,
and then all of a sudden
only spending $100,000
and hoping you're gonna start
becoming viral, right?
So if
that $100,000 doesn't work,
what happens then?
Then, I'll just keep going
and going and marketing this.
And I think that it's
an amazing idea and, like --
But you know how hard it is
to all of a sudden catch fire
after six months in.
But we pay our users
to use the app.
Like, that's really
incentivizing.
You need to tell me
something better
because 100k isn't
a lot.
If we scale
to 100,000 monthly active users
on the app, we will have
$7 million for the year
of gross sales -- total sales.
And that's just doing
a straight line, right?
Yes.
And so -- And then --
That's straight affiliate,
you're saying.
If we add in
the e-commerce, as well.
And your goal is to get
to a bigger affiliate fee
because you're gonna have
direct deals...
-Exactly.
-...with all these providers.
I didn't hear anything
in your business plan
about the army
of business-development folks
you're gonna need
to go do those deals.
Those are hard deals
to do.
They're already cut pretty thin
in their businesses,
and they're certainly
not gonna want to cut
a big, fat piece
of margin for you,
considering
your relative size.
It's gonna take
a lot of time.
But how will you do it?
How are you building that
into your business?
I just think
the biggest issue right now is
finding these brands.
There is no fashion
social network out there.
Well, I would
wholly disagree.
And I'm sorry.
I was an Instagram investor.
Yeah.
I've watched that network
grow up from the beginning.
Right.
It is the fashion
social network right now.
And so, I have friends
like Sophia Bush...
-Right.
-...famous TV star.
Right.
She gets paid directly
by the brands...
-Okay.
-...to model their stuff,
to integrate it, to mention it
in the mentions, right?
Okay.
She's making
so much money doing it
that she's not gonna bring that
traffic over here to your app.
But are her fans happy
with going to her page
and seeing her in a
dress and going, "Oh,
who makes that dress,"
and then they can't directly
tag it and buy it?
'Cause it's annoying.
Look, I disagree
with Chris.
I think a Sophia Bush,
Michelle Phan, whoever it is,
is going to go
where the people are.
But you haven't answered
the most important question --
How are you gonna compel them
to use you?
Just going
and getting P.R.,
just going and spending
marketing dollars...
Right.
...is not gonna do it.
But because you haven't answered
that question, I'm out.
Okay.
Um, So...
-For me,
I think you have
some challenges.
I don't think the highest-end,
most influential people
are gonna come here
because they can do better
just doing stuff direct.
I mean, you're going
after the Holy Grail.
Since the days
I worked at Google,
everyone has said,
"Wouldn't it be amazing
to touch a button
on your TV remote
and be able
to buy the sweater
that Jennifer Aniston is wearing
in 'Friends'?"
-Right.
-Everyone's been chasing this.
I've seen a lot of swings
and misses on it.
You're getting closer, but
I think you also underestimate
how much work it's going to take
to do the deals.
-Right.
-And for that reason, I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Amy, I see Godzilla.
I see you.
And I see you very flat
and a stain on the carpet.
[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-I wish you the best,
but I see bad things
are gonna happen to you.
-Wow.
-I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
Okay.
Well, Amy, you know, I --
You come out here.
You're the real deal.
-Thank you.
-That's right.
You're hip.
I love fashion.
Thank you.
I would love
to work with you,
but I just believe that
the Instagrams of the world,
they're gonna create some form
that you can buy directly
just like this.
And I just think
it's a little too complicated.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
And then,
there was one.
Come on, Barb.
You're ready.
I should probably be listening
to the technology gurus here,
but I'm gonna ignore them.
Are you making an offer?
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Barbara is Amy's last chance
for a deal
for her social-media fashion app
FashionTap.
Okay, Barbara.
You know, I'm thinking
of another entrepreneur
that I invested in
named Grace and Lace.
-Uh-huh.
-The woman who owned
the business made
lacy boot cuffs
for the top of her boots.
It seemed like a long shot.
But ironically,
after all the investments
I've done in the seven years
on "Shark Tank,"
they have been
the most profitable.
And there's
something about you
that reminds me
so much of Grace and Lace.
And so --
Wait, Barbara,
I hear Godzilla.
-Yeah.
-I hear him outside.
Mind your own business,
if you don't mind, "Mr. Baldy."
I'm gonna make you
an offer,
but I need more
for the $100,000.
I need 25%.
Okay.
So, Barbara's made you
a very generous,
blood-sucking offer.
I have total confidence
in you.
O'Leary: Take it.
My goodness, what a chance.
You have escaped a giant foot
that will crush you
and make you a small,
yellow, flat pancake.
And don't even pay attention
to this guy.
-[ Sighs ]
That's coming.
I'm gonna have
to politely decline.
-I just can't.
-Whoa.
Do you have a counter offer?
I really wanted to just go
with the $100,000 for 10%.
-Wow, no flexibility.
-That's non-negotiable.
-Mm.
-Non-negotiable?
-No, because I also have a team.
-No flexibility?
"Shark Tank" platform.
Tens of millions of users.
[ Laughs nervously ]
You're walking out
without a deal?
You're not gonna give her
a counter at all?
-Okay.
-Amy, it's unusual that
an entrepreneur comes in
and sets their price
and it's totally non-negotiable.
-Right.
It's kind of the equivalent
of slamming a door
in someone's face.
-You can always make a counter.
-Well, I mean, if you think of
other apps, pre--
-Revenue?
-You know, users, pre-making --
Their valuations are
$1.5 million to $5 million.
Yeah, and a lot of apps --
A lot of app creators are
working in Payless Shoes
right now 'cause
it didn't work out, so...
O'Leary: Amy, you understand
the difference.
You haven't proven
the monetization of
the business plan yet.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
O'Leary: Wow.
Cuban: Good luck, Amy.
Goodbye, yellow pancake.
Thank you.
[ Chuckles ]
Sacca: Good luck.
-I thought she'd counter.
-You just dodged a bullet.
Roiland:
I came to "Shark Tank" knowing
exactly what I wanted,
and, you know,
they didn't give me that.
But I am very, very excited
about my app and the future,
and I'm not gonna stop.
Narrator: In season 6,
Nayeem Hussain
and Ryan Fant made a deal
with Robert Herjavec
for their smart heating-
and-cooling vent Keen Home.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Hussain: When we first pitched
the Sharks,
our product was eight months
away from completion,
and we had no sales.
Luckily, Robert saw
our vision and invested.
The smart vent is
a technology
that allows people
to zone their heating
and cooling systems
on a room-by-room level.
This not only makes people
more comfortable,
but it saves them
a lot of money.
Hey, looks like this Nest Pro
deal is moving forward.
Great, man.
Since making our deal,
we've done
over $1.6 million in sales.
Hey, guys.
-Hey, Robert. Welcome!
-Wow!
-Good to see you
-How you doing?
Herjavec: I'm in New York City
to meet with the Keen Home guys.
It's interesting --
When they came on the show,
The other foolish Sharks saw
them as a vent product.
This is not a vent company.
This is a tech company.
So, this is
a finished product that we have,
and I can show you
our app.
So cool.
I hear we have a new product.
I'm anxious to check it out.
FANT: So, Robert, this is
our new product.
This is
the Keen Home smart filter.
Herjavec: Wow. Very cool.
How does it work?
So, it enables you to purify air
on a room-by-room level.
So, it clicks in
to our existing faceplates.
Mind blown.
Purifying airflow is
phenomenal, right?
Because you have a huge
indoor-air-quality issue.
But what if you could
odor neutralization to that?
What if you could add
fragrance diffusion to that?
I love it.
You guys are on fire.
Let's keep it going.
Herjavec: The future is
unlimited for Keen Home.
I believed in them
when I saw them in the Tank.
Today, they've expanded
even beyond my vision,
and I'm very optimistic.
All: Keen Team!
[ Cheering ]
Narrator: Next up is a business
that wants to make sure
you never get caught
in the rain.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm John O'Connor.
And I'm
Anusha Kambhampaty.
And we're here seeking
$400,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company 'Brellabox.
What do you do
when a rain storm hits?
You scramble
to find shelter
or maybe attempt to shield
yourself with your jacket.
Or worse yet,
you buy a low-quality umbrella
from a street vendor,
which quickly breaks
and ends up
in the trash.
Because we all know
what happens to a cheap umbrella
in a wind storm.
In fact, every year,
worldwide, we throw away
enough umbrellas
to build 25 Eiffel Towers.
What if you could simply rent
an umbrella?
'Brellabox makes
that possible.
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
-Oh, wow.
-No!
Kambhampaty: Imagine
'Brellabox located strategically
throughout the city
in places like restaurants,
hotels, your apartment building,
your office building,
even the subway system.
Here's how it works.
Using a credit
or a debit card,
for a small fee, you can rent
a high-quality umbrella.
You enter your e-mail address
or your phone number
so that 'Brellabox can
remind you
when your umbrella's due back,
and when the sun comes out,
you return it
to the nearest machine,
which could be found
using our app.
There's no more waste.
There's no more hassle
of having to lug around
an umbrella just in case.
So, Sharks, who wants to set
aside some money for a rainy day
and partner with us?
John: How much is it
to rent the umbrella?
It's $1.50
for 12 hours, right?
So, we've been contacted
by over 23 universities.
How? How did they
find out about you?
Kambhampaty: We had a lot
of press coverage.
We were in
The Wall Street Journal.
We got a mention
in The New York Times.
There you go.
Okay.
A lot of people just gravitate
towards this idea.
Especially in New York
or other walking cities,
people know what it's like
to get caught in a rain storm.
They buy
a street-vendor umbrella.
It breaks.
The cycle continues.
There's a reason
why the street vendors show up
selling the cheap umbrellas
the minute it starts raining.
So give us the numbers.
We have 85% to us,
15% to the university.
And we bring in
a third-party sponsor
to put their sponsorship
on the machines.
So, you can put
the brand name of a sponsor
on the front
of the machine.
All of the umbrellas can be
branded for a sponsor.
It's very similar to Citibike,
which is in New York.
Messaging.
Are any in action
right now?
Do you have
these placed anywhere?
So, we've been
iterating on the machine.
We put one in WeWork.
-[ Groans ]
-What does that mean?
That means they're pre-revenue.
[ Chuckles ]
We put one in WeWork
in the financial district
in New York City.
We did a pilot test run
with one box.
It rain?
Was there demand?
So, there were 16 rainy days
in New York City
during the three months
that we did our pilot program.
On a rainy day,
25 people came through
and used --
-What was the price?
So, the price was free
at WeWork.
And if you didn't return
the umbrella,
what was the charge?
$40.
Have you invested any money
in this yet?
Yes.
Can we have a moment of silence
for that dead money?
[ Laughter ]
Mr. Wonderful,
as much as you love money,
you should listen
to an opportunity
to make some money with this.
-It's so important for me...
-I'm telling you.
-You're so lucky you met me
because I will stop
this madness now.
This is maybe the worst idea
I've ever heard on "Shark Tank."
-The marketplace dis--
-It could be.
It is hideous.
And I don't want you
to waste your lives.
-Wow.
-I'm out.
What do you do when you get
stuck in the rain?
Are you out of your mind? I pick
up an umbrella for $4.99...
Get him.
Get him, Anusha.
...and I throw it out
when it's over.
He melts.
That's what happens.
What does it cost you --
Eleven-fifty to make this
in a limited run
of 50 machines in Kansas.
-Eleven --
-$1,150.
-Okay.
We can get this
down to $975 for 200.
-Let's just say $1,000.
-Okay, let's say $1,000.
Is that
with the umbrellas or no?
We've never paid
for an umbrella.
The largest
umbrella manufacturer has been
giving us umbrellas
for free.
Okay, well, that's good.
Why would they be giving you
the umbrellas for free?
Because if you can put
your umbrella in 'Brellabox
and it withstands the rigor
of being a rental umbrella,
that is consistent
with the brand messaging
that a lot of these large
manufacturers want to have.
You don't think there's
a conversion process there?
It's raining outside.
Like, "Wow, I now have
to put my credit card in.
I'm tired."
I just don't --
I don't do it --
the process.
But remember, you're doing it
in the rain, as well.
And do it in the rain.
And, Daymond, don't forget you
have to return the umbrella.
O'Connor: These are
indoor machines.
You have to return it.
Cuban: See, I look at it
completely different.
Where am I gonna return
the umbrella to, as well?
Why can't you tell
the truth?
It's a horrendously
crappy idea.
Yeah, but if I return it --
Why are you yelling at me?
It's not my company.
Because I'm just worried
about you guys.
I'm worried about you.
[ Laughs ]
Why waste your lives
on such a crappy idea?
O'Connor: Look, look,
we're a real start-up.
We're used to the taste
of blood in our mouth.
You're not the first person
that's criticized this.
Oh, it sucks!
You're not the first person
that's criticized this idea.
The marketplace is
saying something --
Really? I wonder why!
You know what,
Mr. Wonderful doesn't worry
about his hair getting wet.
The rest of us understand
that problem a little bit.
It's horrendous.
Okay, Chris, step up.
Fund this thing.
I'll step up and tell you,
look, I live in California.
I'm sure we won't see rain again
for another five years.
Plus, these shirts are
so full of polyester
and rayon that
they're essentially
a waterproof raincoat
at this point.
And so I haven't suffered from
this problem in a long time.
So for these reasons,
I'm out.
-Okay.
Have you actually taken
an order from anyone?
Yes.
And what is it?
We have an order
from Michigan State University
at their law school --
for one unit.
For how many units?
We're finalizing
our contracts
with East Stroudsburg
University.
Four bo--
-How many?
Four box pilot.
Ultimately, 20 rollout.
Are your umbrellas better,
by the way?
Yes, these umbrellas are
phenomenal quality.
Mr. Wonderful, would you like
to see an umbrella?
-Let me see.
-Sure, show me the umbrella,
but it doesn't change
the outcome.
Corcoran: You want to know
what I think?
I think the umbrellas are
too nice because when I buy
those cheap umbrellas, I'm
throwing them in the garbage.
This is, like, a very heavy,
well-made umbrella.
Yeah, but that's the problem.
You're throwing it away.
And if you decide to keep it,
they make 40 bucks,
and it costs you nothing,
right?
Great. They got your credit
card. You can buy it.
But it's a lot of money
for a little bit of the company
with a lot of uncertainty.
I don't think it's a bad idea.
I think Kevin's wrong.
No, he's right.
It's horrific.
I think there's
opportunity, but --
-We believe deeply in it.
-Say it, Mark.
-We believe deeply.
-Bring it out, big boy.
I believe deeply
in this business.
I'm out.
Okay.
The problem with the idea is
for it to have
any legs to stand on,
you need a lot of boxes.
And for every box
you put on the street,
by the hotel,
in Wall Street, on a campus,
you got to shell out
1,000 bucks of your own money
before you get
any revenue sharing going.
And then, you're sharing
the upside with the university.
Well, that's
where the sponsor comes in.
If a sponsor comes in --
Yeah, but it's
not arranged yet,
and that's
another whole layer of work.
I just don't think
it makes any sense
no matter
how you look at it.
Yeah.
I'm sorry to say I'm out.
-Daymond, please.
-Am I the last one in?
Give them $400,000.
I just don't want
to be disrespectful
towards the fact
that they want to work hard
and create this,
but it's not an everyday item.
I mean, maybe you need
to find a box that puts
something in there
that people need every single
day on the streets of New York.
So I'm out.
All right, guys.
Thanks a lot.
Yep, all right.
-Thank you.
Good luck.
Is that the worst idea
you have ever seen in your life?
No.
It's evil!
It's so bad.
You're gonna have
a whole cult of people
posting wet pictures of you
on the Internet now.
[ Laughter ]
Narrator: Next up is
a product designed
to get kids to eat healthier.
Cute kids.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Bob Ntoya.
And I'm Adam Gerber.
And we're
from Altadena, California,
and our company is
My Fruity Faces.
We're seeking $200,000
in exchange
for 10% of our company.
My Fruity Faces has invented
the --
My Fruity Faces
has invented...
the stick, uh, uh...
-"The solution."
the solution
that families are having,
or parents are having
in trying to get their children
to eat healthier.
Gerber: Like most parents,
my wife and I spend
a lot of time
and energy planning
and preparing
healthy snacks
and healthy lunches
for our kids.
And what do we find
when they return home?
Hot bags of brown,
steamy, rotten mush screaming
to be thrown away.
What a waste.
Well, Sharks,
not anymore.
Say it again.
Thanks
to My Fruity Faces --
Say, "Well, Sharks,
not anymore."
What?
Say, "Well, Sharks,
not anymore."
[ Laughter ]
Well, Sharks,
not anymore.
Zing!
Thanks to My Fruity Faces,
the all-natural, edible stickers
that makes eating fresh fruits
and vegetables fun and exciting.
We've used magical ingredients
mixed with fruity science
to create an all-natural,
safe, edible sticker.
You just peel it,
stick it, and enjoy.
So, Sharks, help us take
a bite out of healthy --
unhealthy snack time.
First of all,
I'd like to thank the kids.
Thanks, kids.
Corcoran: They didn't want
to eat their fruit.
See you, guys.
Nice hat.
[Laughs] Aww, he's so cute.
Look at him.
So, now we'd like to show you
our edible stickers.
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
-Hey, Daymond.
-Hi.
So, now, I put this
on a piece of fruit like this.
And then,
you eat it, yes.
Mmm.
Pretty good.
It's basically
tapioca starch.
Okay, you're selling
a lot of this, right,
'cause you put a $2 million
valuation on this company.
-Correct.
-So, how are sales?
So, we've had
$125,000 worth of sales
in the first three years.
-Whoa.
-Three years?!
-Three years.
-Three years?
-Yeah.
-What did you sell last month?
We sold about $2,000
last month.
Dollars?
Cuban: Ohh, guys.
Yes, and let me explain.
Let me explain.
Here's what's happening.
-You should explain.
Okay, we landed Walmart
about a year and a half ago.
We did our test in 2014.
It went extremely well.
And we're gonna be going
into 3,600 stores.
So far, I'm excited.
What happens next?
So now we just need capital
to basically move forward
for inventory.
But this is real time?
This is right now?
Yes.
Wait a minute.
You have orders --
purchase orders --
Or do you have --
Or you just became
an approved vendor,
and they're discussing
with you rolling you out,
testing you,
in all doors?
The contract basically says
we're a vendor
and that we can go
into 3,600 stores.
Ohh!
Did they give you
a purchase order?
No, no, no.
That's not the same.
They haven't given us
a purchase order, but let me --
[ Both groan loudly ]
I can get the purchase order
and get --
We're actually dealing with
the head of produce in Walmart.
And our discussion
basically was we were looking
for the price point
to go ahead and figure out
whether it's $1.99
or $1.49.
Gerber: We actually did
a test last year.
The sales went great.
Everything went well.
What was
the percentage of sales?
78% sell-through.
Are you working
with any other stores,
or is this the one big store
you've put all your eggs
in that particular basket?
No, we're actually talking
with Target.
We're talking
with SuperValu.
We were talking
to Whole Foods.
-But just early-stage talking?
-Early-stage talking.
And just to add to that,
Sharks, one of the things
that we realized is if we can do
the licensed products --
And we've been
with Nickelodeon.
We actually had
a Nickelodeon license.
We realized with the licensing,
the numbers just shot up.
And how much
have you guys invested in this?
Altogether, we've raised
about $482,000.
-No!
-Ohh! Ohh.
O'Leary: Now, you have
to have some losses here
because you've invested
almost $500,000.
Sales were $2,000
last month.
Do you have debt
on this company?
Yeah, we do --
$177,000.
-Ooh!
-Ohh!
So, you're in
for $660,000, basically.
-Yeah, $600,000.
-Yowza, kiddies.
John: Are you
the sole investors?
No, we actually have 12 other --
10 other investors.
What percentage
of the company do you own,
each one of you?
18% and 17.5%.
Corcoran: Can I clear
the deck a little bit?
The way I see it is
you had $125,000 in sales
over three years.
I just can't imagine
investing my money
and thinking
I'd really get it back out.
so I'm sad
to say I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
And one of the things
that I wanted to add is
we're actually partnering up
with Dole.
So we've realized there's
a tremendous opportunity for us.
I kid you not.
-Yeah, but, guys, you made
the cardinal mistake
of thinking
that money was gonna get
you there quicker.
You didn't do
many sales.
You should have taken
the small amount
of stickers you had
and hit every single school
you could hit,
hit every street fair,
farmer's market,
sold 10,000, 20,000,
50,000, have
a proven concept.
And you just made the cardinal
mistake as an entrepreneur.
And now you're suffering
from it.
I'm out.
How much cash do you have
in the bank right now?
We have about $4,000.
$40,000 -- four-oh?
-$4,000.
-Whoa.
-Guys, Daymond hit
the nail
on the head, right?
When your back is
against the wall, you sell.
Sales cures all.
How much do you have
in inventory right now?
$64,000.
$64,000 of product.
You know, if you sell them
for 2 bucks a pop,
that's $150,000 almost
in retail, right?
So that's just
a matter of your efforts.
Your effort is
the one thing standing
between you
with $4,000 in the bank
and $100,000-plus
in cash.
Guys, I don't think you should
invest more money in this.
I'm out.
-Okay, thank you.
-Thank you.
Sacca: Hey, look,
I admire your hustle.
I admire your drive.
I do absolutely believe
that my kids would eat
more of these things
if they had faces on them.
The problem is
you don't benefit
as a result
of my kids getting healthier.
You sleep better at night
and the world is a better place,
but it doesn't roll up to the
balance sheet of the company.
You're out of money.
You got $4,000 left.
You've got your backs
against the wall.
You're asking for $200,000,
and all that would be enough
to do is pay off your
existing debt on the business.
It doesn't
actually leave you
with a lot
of working capital here.
Too many things have
to go right.
And so far, they're not.
They're going wrong.
I'm out.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, Chris.
I've been fighting
all my life.
I know
that we can make it happen.
I see all the challenges,
and that's why we're here.
If I didn't believe in what
I was doing, I know that --
Belief is not enough.
Mark, what
are you gonna do?
I like the idea.
I like the concept
of licensed characters.
What do you have
in inventory.
-Nickelodeon.
-We have our Nickelodeon.
And you're allowed
to sell it?
Not anymore.
We're looking
to renew our license.
Something's not right.
It's not the idea.
It's not the concept.
It is the execution
100% of the way.
Something's wrong.
And because I have no clue
what that is
and I don't want to be
the one to fix it, I'm out.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, Sharks.
-Good luck, guys.
-Thank you very much.
-Good luck.
-Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
Gerber:
We have a great product.
We have a great contract
for distribution.
We have great licensing.
We have a lot of things
in place.
And the fact
that they couldn't see that is
extremely frustrating.
My name's Dave Vasen.
I live in San Francisco,
California,
with my wife, Simona,
and my daughter, Serena.
Whee!
I'm a first-generation American.
My parents came to the U.S.
from South America
with almost nothing.
They taught me the importance
of a strong work ethic
and the value of an education.
How are we looking
to get this out today?
Vasen: After school, I started
working in education technology,
building software platforms
for big companies like Amazon
and Cisco.
But when my daughter, Serena,
was born, everything changed.
Hi!
Come, run!
Vasen: I would leave
for work every day,
and I just found it so hard
to not be a part of her day
and how she was learning
and growing.
I knew with my background
and passion for education,
I could actually do
something about it.
Everybody,
say, "Cheese!"
Vasen: I developed
a unique product
that's focused specifically
on early education.
It connects preschool
and day-care teachers
to parents
and their children
in a way that's
never been done before.
85% of brain development happens
in the first three years
of life,
and every study shows that
the investment that you make has
a massive impact
not only on the individual
but on the greater community.
These are our kids.
This is our future.
And this is something
that we have to invest in.
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Dave Vasen.
I'm the founder
and C.E.O. of brightwheel.
I'm here seeking
a $400,000 investment
for a 4% equity stake
in my company.
[ Groans ]
brightwheel is the mobile app
for preschools,
day cares, and families.
And we are completely
revolutionizing early education.
Now, I believe
all of us are parents here,
and I want to ask,
when you come home
after a long day and you ask
your kids, "What did you learn
in school today,"
does this sound familiar?
Girl: I did everything.
I did...
I don't want to tell you.
-[ Laughs ]
-You don't want to tell me?
-I don't know!
-[ Laughs ]
Vasen: All right,
this is the experience
for millions of parents
across America every single day
and especially for younger kids.
You've been apart
from your little human being
for 6, 8, 10 hours a day,
and that is all you get.
You know, you want to be
a part of their day.
You want to add to their
learning once you come home.
And you can't.
And it's gut-wrenching.
And on the other side, on
the school side, it's no better.
In addition
to actually educating our kids,
teachers are managing
a ton of paperwork.
Let's face it -- They're
actually managing parents.
And on top of that,
they're even running a business.
The system is broken,
and brightwheel is the solution.
So, let's jump in and take
a look at how brightwheel works.
So, with brightwheel,
teachers can easily check
kids in from the mobile app.
They can log activities
and assessments during the day.
They can send quick updates.
And they can even manage
their business all in one place.
And we're just seeing
an amazing amount of photos
every single day
on brightwheel.
And this is the reason.
You take it, you tag it,
and you are absolutely done.
And now we're gonna look
at the teacher app.
So, this is the teacher's room.
And we're gonna click on
"activities" at the bottom here.
And this is all being done
on paper today.
So, we've taken it
and combined it
and made it super-fast
and super-easy.
And so we're gonna click
on "nap" here,
and then we're gonna tag
three kids
that just went down
for a nap.
And the key about brightwheel is
we're saving teachers time.
You actually have
measurably more time
with kids
every single day.
Now we're gonna flip over real
quick to the parent experience.
So let's jump to the mobile app.
This is actually my little girl,
Serena, and this is her day.
And as you can see,
I get a sense of not only
what she's doing
but what she's learning.
And so, when I come home,
I can actually have
a conversation with her
about it.
My connection
with my little girl is
so much deeper
because of brightwheel.
And by the way, in the middle
of a pretty tough day,
it doesn't hurt
to get a photo like this.
[ Chuckles ]
Sharks, this is
a unique opportunity
to build a massive business
that has a massive impact
on people's everyday lives,
and that's something
that we hear every day.
So, I hope you'll join Serena
and our team
in bringing brightwheel
to every preschool,
every day care, and every family
across the globe.
Are you selling me
this platform, this dashboard?
Is that what's happening?
-Yes.
How much am I paying for it?
Right now,
you're paying nothing.
brightwheel's free today.
When we have
our premium product,
you will be paying
a monthly fee for that.
The parent will pay,
or I'll pay?
You will pay as
the administrator or the owner.
And will the parent
ever pay anything?
Not today.
We're building a platform.
We see a lot of opportunity
to add value to parents
down the road.
Except you can't advertise
on that platform.
Correct, and we have
no intention to advertise.
Wait, you can advertise
to the parents all you want.
We don't want to. We think
there's a ton of ways --
-But you can.
-You'll have a very hard
time with that model.
No way. No way.
No, and we have
no intention to.
So let me walk you through
what brightwheels look like.
So we started with a pilot
in the fall of 2014.
How many schools
did you get signed up?
Yes, so we got 10 schools
in the pilot.
Literally, no product.
And so we worked with them.
We listened to them.
We understood their needs.
In June of this year,
we launched publicly
as brightwheel.
We went from 10,
and then now
we have 2,500 schools.
We're in every state
across the country.
Wow.
So, how are you
gonna monetize this?
First, I just want to say
that when you look
at other industries,
all of these industries
have really great
dedicated software
that's provided
by very large companies.
This is a massive market
that doesn't have that,
and so that's where
we see ourselves fitting in.
Well, a lot of that
has to do with the fact
that they don't have money
because they're very much
small proprietors.
But they do have budget.
Well,
they're just mismanaged.
I've got a 4-year-old,
a 2-year-old, and a 2-week-old,
and I pull
my hair out sometimes
looking at how the preschools
are managed as a business.
And they -- Right.
I offered to write software
for my kid's preschool.
-Yeah?
-And that's why we love it
'cause we take all that
off their hands
so they have more time
with kids.
You're doing
so many things at once.
That makes it a little harder
to pitch this.
Yeah.
That may be where the
opportunity lies, too, right?
You're doing something
for schools,
something for parents,
something for teachers, as well.
Right.
We're in everything
from four-person
in-home day cares, even --
A lot of people are actually
using us with nannies,
so single person --
all the way up to an elite chain
of preschools.
So we're gonna offer
at the low price point
around $40 per month for
a really small in-home day care,
and that scales up
to $200 in terms of the --
So the top price is $200...
Right.
...and that could be
50 kids, right?
There are some
very large centers,
including ones that we're in.
We're in centers
with several hundred children.
So that's --
-That's still 200 bucks?
Yes. Yeah.
Wow.
Have you raised any money
from investors?
So based on the pilot,
we raised a seed round
of $2.2 million
at an $8.2 million valuation.
Besides money, what do you want
the Sharks to contribute
to this --
to your venture?
We're taking on
big challenges now.
We're looking to scale.
We're looking to build
a global brand.
I'm not just here for money.
I'm not just here for PR.
I'm here for
the partnership possibilities
of bringing on Sharks
onto our team
and the value that that adds.
We want to be the brand
of early education.
The problem is
the law of small numbers.
I mean, I actually understand
what you're doing,
and I've been
in your space.
Okay.
I made a lot of money in it,
actually.
And I think it's brilliant.
I think you've done something
really interesting here.
I don't know what your plans are
in the monetization.
So it's $1 million next year,
$6 million the year after that,
and $20 million after that.
I believe it.
Okay, look,
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you $400,000,
but I want 10%.
I just bring too much.
[ Chuckles ]
Kevin, I appreciate that offer.
I really do.
And the fact that you want
to be a part of this,
more than the number
of the equity --
Yeah, but 4% --
How can, like --
It's like...
I understand.
It's, like --
Oh, and look,
your background --
You sold an education company.
That -- That is valuable.
What is challenging for me is
our investors had my back
as a --
-I trust you on that.
-Right. Right.
-But how do I get motivated?
-But you knew that coming in.
I think you're gonna have
that same frustration.
And I mean, you knew
you'd have to negotiate, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, and -- But I want to find
something that works, but --
Well, Dave,
I don't know if I can add value.
Listen, you have Mark
and you have Chris
really savvy in that space.
You have Kevin,
who understands child education.
I don't think I can help you.
I'm out.
I appreciate your time.
I really do.
How many schools are you
gonna add this month?
So we're adding on average --
We added 38 yesterday.
We're averaging
about 40 to 50 a day.
So all right, look,
I really like this business.
I warn you not to promise,
like, we're never
gonna advertise, et cetera,
because I do think
you could add a lot of value
with offers, coupons.
People in this demographic
actually want good products
to be put
in front of them.
And so I think that could be
one fun channel.
Absolutely.
I want to make you an offer,
but I have a hard time
paying more than anybody else
paid for the business,
particularly considering
what I bring with my background,
the value I think I bring
to your platform.
Absolutely.
So I'd like to give you
the 400k you're seeking,
but at the $8.2 million
valuation of the last round.
We give you the 400k,
and we're off to the races.
Can I ask --
You know, first of all,
that is an amazing offer.
Do you have any desire
to team up with other Sharks?
So, if I'm looking
at the other Sharks
and I'm gonna let them
into my deal,
I have to be convinced
that the piece of the deal
I have left
is gonna be worth more
as a result of them being here.
As a result of that, yeah.
And with your company,
I'm not convinced of that.
[ Chuckling ] No!
If we're selling t-shirts
or we need something
at Bed Bath & Beyond,
I got people
lined up over here.
-That translates as,
"You guys are losers."
-Wow.
-A little insulting.
-I don't want to get
in the middle of anything.
You tell me.
What do you think you need
from the rest of the line here?
Are you serious?
Are you really that clueless?
No, I'm just -- I'm...
Seriously,
are you really that clueless?
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Dave has two offers on the table
for his early-education
software platform brightwheel.
However, things have become
heated in the Tank
after Dave suggested Sharks
go in on an offer together.
You tell me.
What do you think you need from
the rest of the line here?
Are you serious?
Are you really that clueless?
No, I'm just -- I'm...
Seriously,
are you really that clueless?
I haven't heard you
speak up, Mark.
I'm listening, right?
Look,
I gave you a great offer.
Chris, I'm -- Chris.
Shark fight!
And I'm confident
it'll hold up.
-Shark fight! Shark fight!
-So if somebody else wants
to speak up right now,
they should.
Chris, I'm --
I'm taking the offer.
I just want to know if --
if we're gonna team up
with anyone, or --
Wait,
you're taking the offer?
So you're not even
listening to anything else?
No, I'm saying
I want in with Chris.
Chris is gonna add
a ton of value.
I want to know if anyone else
wants to join the deal.
I -- I've got two
pending questions.
Yes.
What else do you need
from somebody else?
Right.
And is anybody here
nominating themselves
and bringing something
to the table?
And I haven't heard anything.
-Let me just say --
First of all, I don't need
to nominate myself.
-I'm listening.
-Right?
So I don't need
to convince Chris of anything.
I have no problem with Chris
and the value he brings
to the other companies
he has, right?
When he assigns
his name to it,
it holds
a lot of street cred
in his little part
of the world.
Once you get outside
of that little bubble
called Silicon Valley,
it doesn't mean [bleep]
-As far as I know --
-Ooh. Ooh!
If you want -- If you want
to create a brand value
so that somebody who's working
in Texas, Pittsburgh,
Maine, Florida,
and wants to have
an extra level of confidence
to say, "You know what,
this was validated
by somebody that we trust,
somebody that we know
has a track record,"
your job gets easier.
But that doesn't seem like
a problem
'cause you're in
50 states already.
But hang on.
Hang on.
While the two ends of the Tank
are squabbling like chickens,
I just want
to point something out.
-Yes.
-The only Shark that's ever had
a multi-billion-dollar exit
in your space
is Mr. Wonderful.
Right.
This is my space.
I know exactly
how to help you,
and I think, frankly, I bring
a lot to the table on that.
I'm not gonna fight
with Chris
about whether
he should be alone or not.
To get involved now,
I have to compete with his deal.
So I'm willing to match him
'cause I have no choice.
I like the deal.
I really do.
Right.
Cuban: The percentage
isn't the issue
because it's shuffling
deck chairs on the Titanic.
Either you're gonna make it
or you're not.
Right.
Right?
And so whether it's at 8.2%
or $10 million,
that's not the issue.
Okay.
Are you considering
making an offer?
Yeah, I like it.
So I mean,
he's done most of the work.
It's gonna be those
other schools on the margin
or being able
to get to groups
to create confidence
because the application
does the job.
It does.
And it works great.
Right, so what creates
the confidence...
Right.
...that makes someone
to say yes to a decision
when maybe they don't
understand it completely?
Maybe they're not
in the wheelhouse...
Right.
...of how you're getting
deals currently.
That's the biggest hurdle
we're trying to cross.
David, when you're
asking these guys in,
are you willing to give up
more equity for more money?
And that's what
I'm trying to figure out
so they can even know
how to position themselves.
I would consider it.
We came in here
with -- with a concrete ask
in terms of a -- of a budget.
If it means getting more Sharks
and -- and having more people
at the table,
then I would consider it.
I'll do it either way.
I think partnering with Chris
is smart,
and obviously,
you see the value there.
-Right.
-And I don't mind doing that.
He may not think there's value.
I'll leave that to him.
Or I'll leave it to you
and say I'll hit your number --
400k at the price
that you ask.
-At 4%.
-At the $10 million valuation.
Yeah, because
I have enough confidence
that I add enough value
that it will propel that.
Yeah.
So you're willing to do the deal
at $400,000 at 4%?
Either way, but I do.
Look, regardless of what
he said about me, right,
I see the value there
because I'm --
Silicon Valley's
its own little world.
Yeah. Yeah. Like Uber operates
in its own little world.
Right.
O'Leary: No, but wait a sec.
And Twitter operates
in its own little world.
And Instagram operates
Ooh.
I've never been
outside of San Francisco.
I'm sorry.
Ooh.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, let me ask, then,
Chris, you know,
Mark just asked if you'd be open
to teaming up for a deal.
Is that something
you'd be open to?
What if we do --
So at the valuation
that Mark talked about --
$300,000 from Mark
and $300,000 from Chris?
We get it done, and we build
this thing together.
We're paying more than
the last guys paid, huh?
You're paying 25% more.
At that time, we didn't have --
-Whoa.
-No, don't do it to yourself.
We didn't have the products.
We didn't have the brand.
-Oh. Ohh.
-We didn't have
this team in place.
You didn't have
"Shark Tank," either.
Don't do it to yourself.
I'll do $300,000
and $300,000 at $9 million --
at a $9 million valuation.
Mark, would you do that deal?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
-All right. Right on.
-All right.
Corcoran: Perfect.
-Hug it out, guys. Hug it out.
-[ Laughs ]
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Excited to team up.
-Hug it out.
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-I have no doubt about that.
-Thanks so much, guys.
Guys, come on.
Shake it out. Come on.
-Thank you, guys.
-Nicely -- Nicely done.
Really, really,
really appreciate it.
Congrats, Dave.
Thanks, guys.
I'm so excited
for what this means
for everybody using brightwheel.
These are the exact
right partners that
we wanted in place,
and we're just gonna --
We're gonna take this thing now
to the --
You know, this is a rocket ship.
You know what?
I just thought about this.
They didn't even think
about Kevin O'Leary.
[ Laughter ]
They didn't even
acknowledge him.
I thought it was way too little
for what I bring, anyway.
[ Laughs ]
That's -- That's great.